madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct sur le plateau de la voie et
libre en Bourgogne la descente aux
enfers se poursuit pour Thomas tevenou
le député de sonéloire est visé depuis
mardi par une enquête pour fraude
fiscale après la plainte déposée par la
Commission des infractions fiscales de
Bercy une enquête qui a remise en lum
hier la polémique autour des impôts non
déclarés ou non payé par Thomas tevenou
pendant quelques années l'affaire avait
conduit à sa démission du gouvernement
en septembre dernier Thomas tnou est
donc notre invité ce matin bonjour
bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est la première fois que
vous allez vous exprimer assez
longuement depuis votre démission et la
tempête médiatique qui a suivi nous
allons en parler bien sûr et parler
aussi de politique locale et politique
nationale puisque vous avez conservé
contre vent et Maré votre poste de
député à l'Assemblée nationale nationale
à la maison je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez réagir poser vos questions via
Twitter via notre page Facebook ou par
le biais de du formulaire que vous
trouverez sur notre site internet
bgon.france3.fr alors la révélation de
l'affaire votre démission du
gouvernement ça a suscité d'abord une
certaine incrédulité une incompréhension
la colère après puis un peu le dégoût de
certains de vos électeurs de certains de
vos collègues élus vous allez nous en
parler de nombreux Français vous en avez
pris plein la gueule comme vous l'avez
dit vous-même et on va revoir rapidement
comment tout ça s'est
passé 4 septembre 2014 coup de tonner
après seulement 9 jours passés au
gouvernement Thomas tevennou est
contraint à la démission le furtif
secrétaire d'État au Commerce extérieur
n'avait pas déclaré ou payé ses impôts
pendant plusieurs années la nouvelle
provoque un vrai choc d'autant que
Thomas tou faisait partie de la
commission parlementaire sur l'affaire
kahusac et qu'il se faisait
régulièrement le défenseur de la
moralisation de la vie politique la
République exemplaire c'est le
renforcement des sanctions pénal pour
ceux qui fraudent pour ceux qui n'en
remplissent pas leur devoir fiscal
l'affaire éclate également à quelques
jours du vote de confiance au
gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale la
classe politique est intraitable avec
Thomas tou nous éprouvons tous comme ns
compatriotes une forme de dégoût quand
on n pas au niveau de cette exemplarité
quand on n pas au niveau de cette
éthique on doit être écarté absolument
hallucinant de voir un député qui plus
est engagé dans la lutte contre la
fraude c oubliez de déclarer ses impôts
donc dans ce cas-là on va au moins
demander à ces électeurs de vous
relégitimer quand on n' pas été jugé
digne de rester au gouvernement je pense
que il est difficile de revenir à
l'Assemblée nationale on peut m'accuser
de négligence mais pas de malhonnêteté
se défend de jours plus tard Thas
tevenou dans les colonnes du JSL mais
les impôts sont un sujet sensible après
un moment d'incrédulité ces électeurs
maconis expriment ouvertement leur
colère quand on n'est pas en règle avec
les impôts on ne peut pas se permettre
ensuite d'être le
représentant dans un dans un département
c'est répugnant est-ce qu'il doit rester
député ah bah jeement pas nous quand on
fait une connerie au boulot on nous fout
dehors hein dans la foulée les
révélations s'accumulent Thomas tnou
n'aurait pas payé non plus son loyer
pendant 3 ans des PV des factures d'eau
et d'électricité ou encore des séances
de kiné les condamnations sont unanim
c'est dévastateur pour tout le monde
pour pour la classe politique pour les
Français les députés qui font la loi
doivent être les premiers à se
l'appliquer à à eux-même voilà c'est
tout c'est c'est simple il faut quand
même des repères ça restera une brebie
galeuse je veux dire par là que je vais
pas assimiler toute une génération à
thomatou c'est incompréhensible
invraisemblable je souffre d'une sorte
de phobie administrative se défend
maladroitement le député le président de
la République lui-même évoque l'affaire
lors de sa conférence de presse de
rentrée et il enfonce son éphémère
ministre quand un député de paye pas ses
impôts quand un ministre un compte à
l'étranger même si je ne vais pas faire
une échelle dans les
fautes quand d'autres parlementaires ont
des ennuis avec la
justice pour des faits
personnels ce sont des blessures qui
sont faites à la démocratie la chute est
brutale pour celui qui incarn pour
beaucoup l'avenir de la classe politique
thomas tevennou lui se tait mais résiste
à la pression il revient à l'Assemblée
nationale 28 novembre et siège au
conseil général de son etloire le 19
décembre au cours d'une séance agitée
mais il ne parle pas jusqu'à cette
semaine alors Thomas tous vous êtes
guéri de cette fameuse phobie
administrative dont vous nous avez
parlé B je crois que le terme était
d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit puce que je
crois que les commentaires sont de
vous c'était un terme maladroit parce
que en employant ce terme qui renvoie
une forme de
pathologie je cherchais des
excuses moi je demande pardon à ceux qui
m'ont
soutenu aux électeurs qui m'ont fait
confiance aux électeurs de la première
circonscription de sonelir dont je reste
le représentant à l'Assemblée
nationale je demande pardon au militants
socialistes au sympathisant à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui de gauche mais
aussi pas forcément de gauche euh ont
cru en moi je les ai blessé déçu trahi
je reconnais cette terme et je m'en veux
tous les jours maintenant la question
qui se pose pour moi c'est qu'est-ce que
je fais de ma
vie c'est pas de défendre comme
j'entends mon mandat c'est de sauver ma
peau c'est de sauver l'honneur de mon
nom c'est de sauver l'honneur de ma
famille de défendre mes
filles mon épouse qui a été aussi
victime de mon mauvais comportement et
ESS de redonner un sens à ma vie d'homme
de gauche
engagé c'est aussi et je veux insister
là-dessus de corriger mes fautes de
corriger mes erreurs j'en ai fait et je
veux insister sur un point c'est que
j'ai toujours dit la vérité toujours et
euh
j'ai reconnu mes erreurs immédiatement
je l'ai fait dans le journal de sonéloir
le lendemain de ma démission je l'ai
fait devant le Premier ministre
euh devant mes collègues députés et
depuis ce jour-là je corrige mes erreurs
et je les ai corrigé ça veut dire ça
veut dire que vous comprenez la la la la
la colère que vous avez déclenché mais
comment ne pas la comprendre comment ne
pas la
voir vous avez mis bout à bout les
réactions certain thes
je les considère comme excessives on a
entendu les termes de brebie galleuse on
a entendu le terme d'indignité
nationale porté à mon
encontre moi je corrige mes erreurs mais
je veux pas payer pour tous les autres
et je veux pas que derrière mon nom on
se cache ou on cache toutes les
turpitudes de tous les autres on va y
revenir mais on aimerait comprendre en
fait tout simplement parce que comment
paye pas ses impôts quand on est député
quand on aspire à des oui mais avz omis
de les déclarer quand même enfin ça para
ça paraît incompréhensible pour le le
français moyen qui déclare lui ses
impôts qu' les paye l'administration
fiscale connaissait toute ma vie pour
une raison très simple c'est
que j'avais des indemnités d'élu j'étais
d'ailleurs
prélevé à la source sur mes indemnités
d'élus local de conseiller général je
suis resté conseiller général jusqu'à
mars dernier chaque mois j'étais prélevé
de mes impôts sur les indemnités de
conseiller général
euh mon épouse avait des revenus publics
tout était connu de l'administration
fiscale oui j'ai déclaré en retard oui
j'ai payé en retard mais quand j'ai
entendu que pendant 3 ans je n'avais pas
payé c'est faux h j'ai été prélevé une
dame tout à l'heure dans le reportage
disait quand on fait une connerie euh
ben on se fait rattraper par
l'administration fiscale mais elle m' R
comme tout le monde avec des pénalités
j'ai payé toutes les pénalités
correspondantes vous savez dans ma vie
d'élu j'ai fait un certain nombre
d'intervention auprès des impôts pour
obtenir soit la bienveillance soit un
échelonnement pour un certain nombre de
mes concitoyens qui venaientent me voir
en disant on y arrive plus moi je défie
quiconque de trouver une intervention
signée de ma main en ma faveur je n'ai
bénéficié d'aucune indulgence d'aucun
passe- droit j'ai payé toutes les
pénalités prévu par la loi je les ai
payé au centimes d'euros près et j'ai
été prélevé pardon je termine j'ai été
prélevé aussi sur mes indemnités
parlementaires c'est-à-dire que
concrètement il y a certains mois où
l'administration fiscale a prélevé sur
mes indemnités parlementaires le montant
des impôts dus donc tout le monde savait
à l'Assemblée nationale à
l'administration fiscale partout tout le
monde bien sûr mais comment imaginer le
contraire alors comment ça se fait un
député membre de la commission des
finances qui euh a des retards et vous
croyez que personne le sait personne
alors pourquoi je rappelle que le
rapporteur général du budget à
l'Assemblée nationale a des pouvoirs
extraordinaires qui lui permet de
regarder tous les dossiers fiscaux tous
les dossiers fiscaux euh des
parlementaires des journalistes des
personnes en vue de n'importe qui ce
rapporteur général du budget en 200 12
quand je suis arrivé à la commission des
finances s'appelait Christian ert il est
depuis devenu ministre du Budget
évidemment que tout le monde savait tout
le monde savait que j'avais des
problèmes au gouvernement aussi mais
alors pourquoi vous êtes en nommé
sachant le le retentissement qu'une
telle affaire pouvait avoir parce que je
pense qu'on estimait que je pouvais
faire mon job mon
travail parce que je pense que certains
pensaient que c'était pas si grave que
ça euh en tout cas moi
la question que je me pose c'est pas
celle-ci la question que je me pose
c'est pourquoi j'ai accepté moi oui
j'allais vous poser la question mais
c'est ça la question il faut la question
que vous avez posé sur est-ce qu'il
savaient ben il faut leur poser la
question à ceux qui étaient censé savoir
moi je me pose la question pourquoi j'ai
accepté et sachant que ça allait
forcément vous rattraper vous savez très
bien oui mais premièrement quand vous
êtes appeler au Gouvernement de la
République
française que toute votre vie vous
l'avez passé c'est à servir votre pays
votre département votre ville vos
électeurs et que Laurent fabus en
l'occurrence m'appelle pour me dire j'ai
pensé à vous pour vous occuper du
commerce extérieur de la France et pour
essayer de le redresser c'est très
compliqué de dire non il y a aussi je
l'avoue une forme
d'aveuglement qui me caractérisait et
une forme d'ambition peut-être démesuré
qui m'a fait perdre un certain nombre de
sens des des priorités mais vous croyez
que quand ils l'ont fait ils n'était pas
au courant vous croyez sérieusement que
ils appellent un député membre de la
commission des finances porte-parole du
groupe parlementaire socialiste j'ai
failli être nommé en avril 2014 vous
vous en souvenez peut-être oui bien sûr
c'était pour une autre mission à
l'époque c'était pour s'occuper plutôt
des transports j'étais déjà en pointte
sur la l'écotaxe la RCEA sur les
taxis ça ne s'est pas fait à cette
époque- là 6 mois avant dans le
gouvernement Vals 1 entre Vals 1 et Vals
2 personne n'a rien
vérifié ça me disculle pas ça ne discule
pas mes fautes ça ne remet pas en cause
le fait que j'ai fait des fautes oui et
ben je les corrige que tout le monde
fasse de même que tous ceux qui font des
erreurs fasse de même dans la sphère
publique il y a un certain nombre
d'hommes et de femmes politiques qui
font parfois des erreur j'ai entendu
Alain Jup il a été condamné il a payé
lui aussi pourrait avoir un petit
peu de mansuétude ou en tout cas quand
je dis que j'ai le droit à la deuxième
chance é plutôt il était plutôt retenu
he il était plutôt retenu d'ailleurs
quand on regarde politiquement les
choses euh mes amis ont chargé oui vous
le renvoulez je m'en veux à moi c'est
moi le responsable de ça comment vous
avez vécu ouais mais comment vous avez
vécu justement là c'est ces 9 mois on
vous a peu vu ce qu'on peut comprendre
comment vous vous avez vécu vous avez
éteint votre télé votre vot radio euh tu
veux pas rentrer dans le détail il a
fallu d'abord protéger euh protéger euh
nos filles les sortir de l'école euh
voilà les télés étaient euh en bas de de
notre domicile parisien elles sont même
montées dans la cage d'escalier de mon
domicile Clunisois euh elles ont fait
intrusion dans ma vie privée donc le la
première chose à faire c'est de protéger
les siens protéger ses enfants mes
filles en l'occurrence nos filles mon
épouse et mes parents parce que il se
trouve que j'ai la chance d'avoir des
parents jeunes mon père habite dans la
circonscription sonéoir ma mère n'habite
pas dans le département mais eux aussi
quand il dégustent il faut essayer de
les protéger donc on on essae de les
protéger de tout faire pour les protéger
et puis on corrige ses fautes moi je les
ai corrigé du jour où le Premier
ministre m'a convoqué
le jour où le Premier ministre me
convoque je suis en règle et je viens
dans son bureau en lui disant je suis en
règle h voilà et c'était trop tard mais
c'était trop tard il a jugé que c'était
trop tard enfin il l'a pas jugé lors de
ce premier rendez-vous il l'a jugé 3
jours après lors d'un deuxième
rendez-vous mais lors du premier
rendez-v pourquoi selon vous voilà parce
que ça a suscité beaucoup d' moins vous
savez que les Français la question des
impôts elle est hyper sensible mais mais
je je je sais tout ça et on était dans
une période particulière puisqu'on était
au début du mois de septembre h au
moment où euh les français payent le 3è
tiers j'observe d'ailleurs que cette
semaine on est dans un autre moment
particulier puisque les Français sont en
train de déclarer sur Internet ceux qui
ont fait comme moi leur déclaration
papier je l'ai fait le 11 mai par accusé
réception je suis mensualisé j'en
profite pour le dire de toute façon rien
n'a été caché de ma vie donc donc je
paye des impôts chaque mois de manière
mensualisée je ne dois plus aucun
centime et évidemment j'ai déclaré en
temps et en heure il se trouve que cette
semaine l'administration fiscale a porté
plainte contre moi le parquet a
déclenché une enquête préliminaire mais
il y a eu un autre événement cette
semaine qui est arrivé jeudi après-midi
j'ai reçu un courrier de la Haute
Autorité de la transparence de la vie
publique qui me
blanchit et qui va transmettre ma
déclaration de patrimoine et ma
déclaration d'intérêt à la préfecture de
sonéoir pour qu'elle soit consultable
par chacun des citoyens et qui vous
blanchit de quoi qui me blanchit qui dit
ceci pour être précis monsieur tevenou
dans sa déclaration de patrimoine n'a
pas indiqué qu'il avait un passif fiscal
de 16000 € à la date du 31 janvier 2014
c'est
tout que j'ai eu des retards d'impôt
toute la France est au courant c'est pas
vraiment une nouvelle mais ça veut dire
que tout ce que je raconte depuis 3
jours sur le fait qu'il n'y a pas de
revenu caché qu'il n'y a pas de contrat
à l'étranger et qu'il s'agit bêtement
connement juste d'un problème de retard
ça la Haute Autorité de la transparence
de la vie publique le reconnaît et elle
ne porte pas plainte contre moi elle a
porté plainte contre d'autres
parlementaires depuis 6 mois
qui ont des comptes à l'étranger ou qui
ont dissimulé des revenus ou qui ont
sous-estimé leur patrimoine elle a même
fait des remarques à des ministres qui
sont toujours en exercice qui ont qui
ont sous-estimé leur patrimoine moi du
patrimoine j'en ai pas mon seul
patrimoine c'est une maison rue de
Montchevrier à montsolémine que je
n'arrive pas à vendre c'est mon seul
patrimoine h il est évalué à 120000 €
voilà et donc non mais c'est très
important parce que dans la même semaine
où vous avez les services de Bercy qui
dépendent du gouvernement qui c'est
c'est une autorité indépendante la
Commission des infractions fiscales il y
a des au magistrats la Commission des
infractions fiscales a autorisé Bercy à
déposer plainte mais qui dépose
plaininte dans cette affaire c'est pas
la Commission des infractions fiscales
c'est le DG FIP en l'occurrence le
collaborateur direct du ministre du
Budget c'est Bery qui a déposé plainte
c'est pas la CF la Commission des
infractions fiscales donc dans la même
semaine où vous avez un service qui
dépend du gouvernement qui porte plainte
contre moi vous avez la Haute Autorité
mise en place après l'affaire Cahusac
indépendante qui m'a reçu la rapporteur
d'ailleurs m'a dit vous n'êtes pas un
fraudeur vous êtes un contribuable
négligant je lui ai demandé de répéter
cette phrase elle l'a répéter devant moi
et devant mon avocat et bien cette
autorité ne porte pas de plainte contre
moi est-ce qu'il y a pas deux poids de
mesure est-ce qu'il y a pas un problème
une contradiction entre la plainte qui a
été déposée contre moi au début de
semaine et l'avis de la Haute Autorité
oui mais vous vous le savez c'est dans
le le le code des impôts quand on paye
pas ses impôts on a des pénalités mais
on peut aussi avoir des sanctions
pénales c'est c'est la lo pay j'ai payé
j'ai payé mes pénalités oui mais il y a
il est prévu aussi des sanctions pénales
éventuellement est-ce qu'il est euh
reconnu que j'ai organisé un système de
fraude fiscale non la Haute Autorité le
dit elle dit qu'il n'y a que des retards
h moi je n'ai pas de compte à l'étranger
je n'ai pas dit dissimulé du patrimoine
je n'ai pas sous-estimé mon patrimoine
je n'ai pas organisé mon insolabilité
oui je sais qu'on l'a bien compris mais
face au déferlement que vous avez
rappelé et remontré au début de
l'éission j'ai aussi le droit de me
défendre vous comprenez je je suis pas
auudessus des lois mais je suis pas en
dessous non plus j'ai le droit aussi
parce qu'il y a des milliers de Français
qui sont comme moi pris à la gorge par
l'administration fiscale et qu'il faut
aussi défendre et quand on a payé ces
pénalités moi j'ai remboursé le
préjudice je n'ai pas volé l'État le
préjudice de mes retards a été remboursé
par les pénalités qui sont pas des
petites pénalités quand vous payez 20 %
de plus sur votre impôt sur le revenu
c'est pas rien j'ai payé mais alors
pourquoi un acharnement vous avez parlé
d'acharnement cette semaine mais qui
parce que je pense que je pense que mon
nom est devenu un symbole je pense que
le nom de tevenenou qui est connu dans
la France entière est devenu un symbole
et que derrière ce non ça permet de ne
pas parler de tout le reste ça permet de
se racheter une
exemplarité on parle beaucoup
d'exemplarité d'exemple ben mon nom sert
d'exemple voilà on est intransigeent
mais très bien qu'on soit intransigeent
on m'a quand même viré du gouvernement
ma femme a été virée elle est au chômage
on a payé on a payé à tous les sens du
terme qu'est-ce qu'on veut rajouter
encore une pêleté de terre on peut le
faire mais moi ça ne me fera pas fléchir
j'ai une mission j'ai une mission de
parlementaire a effectuer jusqu'au
dernier jour et jusqu'au dernier jour je
ferai ma mission de parlementaire et
d'homme politique je ne suis pas qu'un
contribuable négligeent je suis un homme
politique un homme public et dans son
travail politique et publi je pense que
je l'ai fait mon travail et j'ai été
utile à la circonscription à la
sonéloire et un peu au pays quand j'ai
réglé la question des taxis que vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure il y a 18
mois c'était quasiment la guerre civile
à Paris il y avait des grèves générales
sur le périf Paris était bouclé
aujourd'hui vous en entendez plus parler
bon c'est pas
tomber du ciel tout ça il a fallu
travailler c'est ce que j'ai fait et
c'est ce que je continue à faire dès
aujourd'hui dès hier dans ma
circonscription mon travail de
parlementaire et c'est
facile les gens disent ça doit être
compliqué là parce que tout le monde
doit vous parler que de que de que de
cette affaire non les gens ne me parlent
pas que de cette affaire j'ai repris mon
bâton de pèlerin comme j'ai toujours
fait fait c'est-à-dire que je fais ce
que j'appelle des visites de communes
avec le maire les adjoints et la
population on parle de tout de tous les
sujets et à la fin quand on n' pas parlé
du sujet c'est moi qui pose des
questions est-ce que vous avez des
questions personnelles à me poser si je
suis resté député c'est pour rendre
compte et y compris dire expliquer pas
me justifier je n'ai pas
d'excusees très bien mais je peux quand
même dire ma vérité qu'elle a été ma vie
depuis 20 ans consacrée aux autres en
reniant toujours plus sur la partie
privée familial personnel où je me suis
consacré complètement d'abord à mon
soléine et ensuite comme beaucoup
d'hommes politiques cela dit mais mais
c'est pour ça que je suis pas mieux que
les autres et je suis peut-être je suis
peut-être pas un exemple à suivre ça je
le reconnais volontiers mais en même
temps je ne veux pas qu'on m'accable de
toutes les fautes qu'est-ce que me
disent les gens ils me disent hier vous
savez j'étais j'ai vu vu des gens des
élus des responsables associatifs
j'étais à aé à la cave coopérative j'ai
vu des viticulteurs qui m'ont posé la
question l'un a fait une allusion aux
impôts j'en ai profité alors posez-moi
des questions ils me disent d'abord
faites votre boulot vous êtes là pour
faire votre boulot de parlementaire vous
avez décidé de rester parlementaire
alors vous faites votre boulot
ensuite vous vous défendez vous avez le
droit aussi de vous défendre trè
on n'est pas tout à fait dupe donc je
vais faire mon boulot et je vais le
faire jusqu'au dernier jour parce que la
véritable imposture ça serait de dire
j'occupe un siège je ne fais rien et je
me me représente pas je trava non je
travaille et je vais être utile à ce
territoire et je le suis tous les jours
tous les jours et est-ce que vous vous
représenterez en 2017 oui parce que
l'imposture ça serait de dire de toute
façon moi je sais que je vais pas me
représenter donc j'occupe le siège sans
rien faire non je travaille et je me
représenterai et comme ça chacun pourra
choisir si on veut encore de moi et bien
on me garde si on veut plus de moi en
toute connaissance de cause je suis le
député dont on connaît tout la vie
publique avec ses réussites la vie
privée avec ses ses défauts je n'ai pas
des défauts dans la vie
privée j'ai un défaut j'ai un défaut qui
était de déclarer en retard et de payer
en retard ce défaut est corrigé j'ai
corrigé mes erreurs que chaque homme ou
femme politique qui s'est exprimé tout à
l'heure dans votre reportage regarde ses
défauts ses erreurs et les corrigeent
tous les jours moi c'est ce que je fais
tous les matins c'est comme ça que vous
pensez sauver votre peau mais en
redemandant aux électeurs j'essaie de
d'expliquer ma vie qui n'est pas celle
d'un fraudeur qui n'est pas celle d'un
Cahusac moi j'ai pas un radis mes
parents n'étaient pas dans la
politique mon père s'occupe du chômage
des jeunes à montsoléine ma mère était
pharmacienne ils n'ont jamais fait de
politique je ne suis pas un héritier je
n'ai pas d'épargne je n'ai pas d'argent
caché je n'ai pas de compte à Singapour
j'ai consacré 20 ans de ma vie à ça et
je veux qu'on comprenne ce que ça a
représenté comme réussite mais aussi
comme erreur la chute a été brutal du
coup vous avez tout vous avez tout gâché
c'était une espèce de de et d'ailleurs
il y a il y a un twit qui nous le dit
c'est une espèce de suicide politique ce
que vous avez fait non
oui mais si on parle du suicide euh je
je bon on arrive sur des questions plus
plus intime moi je je non mais je parle
de vraiment de suicide politique parce
que là ça vous a cassé les B vous parle
de de je reprends votre
terme moi je veux pas parler je veux pas
utiliser ce mot-là parce que la vie elle
continue il y a des milliers de Français
gâé votre carrière mais il y a des
milliers de
Français
qui par une négligence par une erreur
par une faute gâche leur carrière comme
vous dites leur vie mais ces Français là
qui connaissent la rupture la rupture
professionnelle la rupture personnelle
qui connaissent la maladie qui
connaissent les preuves ces Français là
ils ont aussi le droit à une deuxième
chance moi si on veut pas de moin en
2017 on me le dira les électeurs auront
le pouvoir de me le dire ils m'en
verront balader très bien mais moi j'ai
le droit de dire aujourd'hui que dans
cette société des gens qui ont fait des
erreurs quand ils les assument et quand
ils les corrigent ils ont aussi droit à
une deuxième chance mais c'est pas que
pour moi Thomas tnou député de la
première circonscription on s'en fiche
on s'en fout c'est pour tous ceux qui
comme moi ont connu mais il y en a il y
en a plein et pas qu'avec les impôts
vous savez il y a plein de gens qui ont
du mal à s'en sortir pas que
financièrement à se sortir de la
dépendance à l'alcool à la drogue aux
difficultés psychiatriques euh aux
problèmes d'argent au surendettement moi
je suis là pour dire que oui on peut
s'en sortir on peut corriger ses fautes
on peut avoir droit à une deuxième
chance c'est une c'est pas une une
histoire politique c'est aussi une leçon
de vie c'est une leçon de vie pour moi
parce que le comportement que j'avais ne
pouvait pas continuer que la chute a été
brutale mais que finalement tout ça a
quelque chose de positif pour moi mais
la la pente va être dure à à remonter
hein on voit on voit beaucoup de gens
qui disent il est quand même gonflé on
le revoit à la télé aujourd'hui on vous
a vu euh à la Une à la unee de
libération vous avez souhaité que je
vienne vous m'avez invité on vous a
invité vous avez accepté pour la
première fois depuis septembre c'est
c'est un peu c'est un peu ironique quand
vous dit on on le voit à la télé vous
avez souhaité que je m'exlique je ne
parle pas de c'est pas mon avis moi je
ne suis pas juge je suis journaliste je
POS des question donc moi je m'explique
vous m'avez invité je viens ici et je
donne ma vérité après la pente est-ce
qu'elle sera dure à remonter ça c'est à
moi d'en juger c'est à moi d'en juger
mais on vous voit à la Une de Libération
là ça vous voulez dire quoi ce ce mardi
cette photo les les gens ont pas bien
compris en fait mais vous avez été
beaucoup brocardé hein sur Internet
j'insiste là-dessus moi je suis pas en
train de prendre des pauses pour des
photographes j'essaie de sauver ma peau
c'était pas une pause là choisi écoutez
je le photographe
arrive il me dit on va prendre une photo
de vous je lui dis on est à l'Assemblée
nationale dans mon bureau je lui dis on
peut la prendre dans ce bureau il me dit
non c'est trop petit je vous raconte
l'histoire parce que encore une fois
c'est des histoires de vie il me dit on
va se mettre dans le couloir il est en
travaux c'est très bien vous allez
monter sur ses plaintes je lu dis mais
vous trouvez pas que c'est un peu
étrange comme photo mais de quel droit
j'ai quel est mon droit c'est vreimage
quand même mais enfin je et lui il est
photographe vous êtes journaliste vous
avez le droit de dire ce que vous voulez
sur moi d'ailleurs vous n'en êtes pas
privé et le photographe il peut aussi
avoir son œil sa vision de moi et moi je
vais lui dire non parce que mon image
j'en suis plus là la question c'est pas
de savoir quelle est mon image et mes
posuses c'est de sauver ma peau et
l'honneur de mon nom et celui de ma
famille voilà alors cette photo après on
peut l'interpréter de différentes
manières moi j'ai mon interprétation
mais c'est peut-être pas celle du
photographe en tout cas je laisse des
gens libres La voix est Libre les
photographes aussi les journalistes
aussi et moi je veux être libre aussi de
dire ce que je vais ce que et vous allez
avoir encore l'occasion après la pause
puisque il est midi c'est l'heure des
infos avec Arnaud Lefèvre à tout de
suite